President Trump is in Italy this morning
meeting with other leaders of the
world's biggest economies
the group of seven posed together before
discussing security terrorism and
climate change
Margot Brennan is traveling with the
president on the final stop of his
international trip and she is in
Taormina Sicily Margaret good morning
good morning while some fractures
between the US and its allies are
visible on the president's final stop a
sharp contrast to that warm reception he
got in the Middle East all six major
industrialized powers are trying to
convince President Trump of the merits
of free trade and the global threat of
climate change we can go out of the
world leaders will urge the president to
stick with the 2015 Paris agreement to
cut greenhouse gas emissions the
president has not yet decided we'll be
discussing terrorism President Trump
told japan's Prime Minister that his
focus is on security cooperation he will
also see UK prime minister Theresa May
who yesterday spoke to him about leaks
from US officials regarding the
Manchester attack intelligence that is
shed between law enforcement agencies
must remain secure mr. Trump promised to
launch a review and said leaks of
sensitive information pose a grave
threat to our national security at that
NATO summit President Trump drew
attention with some aggressive posturing
brushing by the prime minister of
Montenegro and with too intense
handshakes with France's new president
23 of the 28 member nations are still
not paying what they should be paying
and what they're supposed to be paying
for their defense mr. Trump is not the
only u.s. president to urge allies to
increase military spending but he is the
first to not explicitly commit to NATO's
collective defense clause an attack on
one is an attack on all and he made no
mention of Russia's aggression in Europe
which NATO was originally founded to
counter EU leader Donald Tusk said the
allies do not see eye to eye and I am
not 100% sure that we can say today we
means mr. president and myself that we
have a common position common opinion
about Russia Charlie after the next 24
hours of meetings president Trump
returns to Washington on Saturday thanks
Margaret Brennan in Sicily